المشاركه في المعارك لا تقتصر على حمل
سلاح فحسب بل تشمل مهاما اخرى من بينها
التنقيب على جثه الجنود القتلى فالعثور
على جثه الجنود المتوفره في الحرب يساعد
في التعرف على مصير الالاف من المفقودين
مجموعه من المتطوعين الاوكران تكفلوا بهذه
المهمه الانسانيه في مناطق مختلفه من
اوكرانيا وينتمي جامع الجثث المتطوعون الى
مجموعه تسمي نفسها بلاك توليب وتضم هذه
المجموعه حوالي عشره متطوعين هذه المجموعه
هي واحده من عده مجموعات بالاضافه الى
الوحدات العسكريه الاوكرانيه التي تجوب
مناطق القتال بحثا عن الجثث يقولون انهم
اكتشفوا جثه
311 جنديه روسيا في مناطق متفرقه منذ
فبراير
لكن لماذا جثث الجنود الروس بالتحديد
المجموعه الاوكرانيه تهدف بشكل اساسي الى
جمع تلك الجثث لتمكين الجيش الاوكراني من
تبادلها فيما بعد مع الجانب الروسي وتضم
عمليه التبادل على الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه او على خط المواجهه تحت اشراف
السلطات العسكريه في البلدين وبحضور
اللجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر وتبقى عمليه
التعرف على هويه الجنود المتوفين عمليه
اساسيه لاحصاء عدد ضحايا الحرب ويزعم
اعضاء هذه المجموعه الاوكرانيه المتطوعه
ان الجيش الروسي يعمد الى احراق جثث بعض
جنوده المتوفين وذلك بغيه التقليل من حجم
خسائره في الحرب